[Music]
from director Tim Burton the inspiration
behind most Hot Topic merchandise comes
another corporate mandated post
converted 3d reboot that this time and
explicably made over a billion dollars a
billion this is why we can't have nice
things
Alice in Wonderland you fell in love
with Lewis Carroll's playful story books
and sat in all of Disney's beautiful
animated film now head down the rabbit
hole once again to watch the once
brilliant Tim Burton who always defied
convention with brilliant new stories
and visionary ideas become a complete
parody of himself and bungle yet another
iconic franchise for a paycheck Alice is
all grown up and this not quite a sequel
featuring nightmarish CGI versions of
your favorite characters gah who'd want
to buy any of those on a t-shirt join
these ugly characters for a forced in
generic storyline about a young adult
being the chosen one destined to save
the kingdom from the evil monster
because apparently Narnia Harry Potter
Percy Jackson the neverending story
didn't beat that dead horse enough he
entered the joyless bombed-out
post-apocalyptic wasteland known as
Underland seriously Wonderland is
Underland now watch your childhood
wither and die as its replaced by a
sepia-tone hellhole
of animal cruelty creatures licking open
wounds and creatures getting stabbed in
the eye
ah roll your eyes at the world's least
inspired casting choice as Johnny Depp
plays a pasty weirdo see burdens man use
as the Mad Hatter whose character is now
vastly expanded with a PTSD backstory
actual hat making and whatever the [ __ ]
this is
since burden can't cast Johnny Depp is
everyone get ready for Helena
bonham-carter as the Red Queen who
you'll hate because we're non-stop
shrieking and stupid bubble head and
Anne Hathaway as the white queen who you
hate because it's Anne Hathaway against
my vows at the center of it all is Alice
a nonconformist dreamer who won't do
what some dragon-slaying prophecy tells
her to do this is my dream I will decide
where it goes from here she's gonna be
her own independent woman and slay the
dragon just like the prophecy told her
to do girl power
so slog through another one of Tim
Burton's farted out kooky adaptations
crammed with all the elements of a goth
teenagers wet dream like emotional
detachment Victorian costumes frowning
tears and really really really white
people
starring pale weird Johnny Depp hey a
weird Helena bonham-carter
pale weird Crispin Glover pale weird
Anne Hathaway and introducing pay a
weird Mia Wasikowska Alice in Wonderland
you know Tim Burton didn't actually
direct Nightmare Before Christmas right
it's true I have to be honest be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers I
fart in your general direction your
mother was a hamster and your father
smelt of elderberries curse your sudden
but inevitable betrayal let them fight
get that cord out of my face you're a
funny guy Sully I like you that's why
I'm going to kill you bye